but uh
but somewhere you know just about six
months before i went to college i met an
older woman while i was working in a
supermarket
uh and her name was linda
and very attractive uh and like i was
not quite 18
and she was about 32 so it was sort of a
mutual attraction and seduction whatever
word you want to use
we wound up having an affair uh i found
out
soon after that she was married i knew
she had two kids
but i never met the husband the husband
was always gone
he was always away so i was assuming he
was a businessman or
a doctor just with crazy hours get that
thing a little bit closer to you okay
just pull it just pull it towards your
head yeah yeah and uh or you can scoot
yeah either way and ultimately i find
out
later on uh that he is
one of the bosses in the columbo family
and his name is greg scarp and they
called him the grim reaper
he had the i mean he told me he stopped
counting at 50 bodies
and he's probably got 100 or 200 i mean
it's
uh well probably one of the most feared
mob guys in history uh yeah so
holy [ __ ] yeah the way i found out was
now sorry interrupt when you were that
age did you know anything about
mafia not a lot i knew
uh there was these social clubs all over
the place where the guys always dressed
better and never worked and had the
caddies that type of thing you knew it
was there
but i didn't know anything about uh the
rules or the
the uh uh the real actual lifestyle
the life i didn't really know what it
would have meant to be in that life
uh until later on obviously so
and i did have an uncle albert who was a
dinosaur with the columbo family
he died at like 93 years old or 94 years
old
and he was very very well liked
in and out of that life he was one of
those guys that you see in
like in movies where they like the mob
guy he was that guy
greg on the other hand was just a
vicious uh
greedy you know uh
ruthless mob guy so uh and i've wound up
somewhere in between because
growing up under greg's carpet
you had to produce you couldn't be weak
uh you couldn't show any weakness
so i learned to be a
a gangster like greg okay so
you're having an affair with this woman
who's
over more than 10 years older than you
and
then you find out that she's married to
a guy who's a
infamous murderer how does that not
freak you out how do you not run for the
hills it did it did but here's what
happened
she broke it like
little bits and pieces she said told me
first he was an influential guy
he could help you in business and they
actually put me in charge
of sales their sales they had a company
uh paper products and fire extinguishers
cleaning supplies
to furnish all kinds of businesses
restaurants and
uh they just made me the sales manager
just came in
and she told him that she had a guy that
can do it and
next thing i know i meet him that way uh
so now going to different establishments
to get the business
if they said no the next day he would
send somebody
to the place and say all right larry
you'll go back tomorrow i would go back
they were so happy to sign me up
so the business was i started
understanding you know
uh of exactly what he was
but where i she was strong-arming people
to do business with you yeah to get to
make sure they gave me the business yes
that was his influence uh and it was
going well for a while
but what happened was because now i
knew him personally and he was helping
me and making me successful in this
first legitimate business i started
feeling guilty and paranoid
i says now it's really really bad if he
finds out he's got to kill me
you know i know who he is now so this
went on for months
and he saw the you know i did some
things that
were paranoid like when he would call me
to a meeting i wouldn't go
i said he's going to kill me tonight you
know uh or if he wants me to drop him
off downtown or bring him somewhere
and i was always the one to do it but i
started boris one of these trips i'm not
coming home
you know because he's gonna find out
about you yeah so
ultimately somewhere along the way they
discussed it
or uh she told him
you know there's a lot of theories now
there's people think he might have known
from the very beginning
very possible uh some say
well the other thing you got to know is
he had two other wives
yes at the same time yes so he had three
he had one that was living in vegas an
israeli beauty queen
he had uh connie who was his first wife
uh with his first children and
uh and then he had linda who actually
was a common law
i don't think i'm pretty sure they never
got married you know
we found that out later on so he was
juggling three lives uh three wives and
three lives
so the other theory is that i made it
easier for him because his youngest wife
now
wasn't going to complain when he wasn't
around she had you know her own little
toy
or her own keeping her occupied right so
uh
so anyway he confronts me with it one
day we're driving to the club
and he knew because just a couple of
days earlier
i didn't show up somewhere and he said
this is not like you he says something's
wrong
so on the way he started breaking the
ice it's just
us two in the car and we would get to
the club every day about a half hour
before the rest of the men showed up
and on the way he's saying things like
he
loves me like a son you know linda loves
you
uh i'm gonna have this conversation with
you because i think you're very
mature for your age i'm only 19 now this
was about a year and a half later we had
this talk
and we wound up getting out of the car
walking into the club
we go he sits down behind the desk i sit
in my spot
on the other side of the desk like we do
every day and he's going on and finally
he says
i know about you and linda so
my heart's beating and i remember always
saying that i would never admit it
i would never ever admit it i said i
just have to deny it
but something came over me like it was
uh do or die it was
time i mean i i loved i didn't want to
not be with her
uh and my answer to him was greg
i have a lot of respect for you you know
that and i
think you are far from an idiot but only
an idiot wouldn't see it what was going
on
i mean he knows i'm there you know
you know constantly i'm with her all the
time even when he's away
uh you know and i i didn't believe he
really thought i was helping her around
the house and shopping for her
you know i mean come on uh after all
this time
so i sort of maybe deep inside i
knew that he knew it's just a weird
weird time it was very rough it was
tough but
now the weight of the world was off my
shoulders but i did
learn one of the main rules that day
he took me outside you know we would
hang out on a parking meter lean under
me to get some sun
and he told me that
it's okay he says i'm fine with it if
anybody outside the three of us
finds out he says you and i will be
killed
it's a rule somebody could kill the grim
reaper well
yeah we're breaking a uh one of the
rules that is told to you the day you
become a made guy
you know you never turn on the family
you you have to
uh come whenever the family calls for
you they come first
no drugs obviously america no talking to
the law
and no messing around with other
people's wives or girlfriends
you know so i learned that rule that day
but as the years went on
i also learned every one of those rules
is broken
foreign